- In Detroit over the last three years
over 100,000 families have
had their water shut off.
I can't touch water or drink water
or be in contact with water
without thinking about somebody
not having it.
My name is Monica Lewis-Patrick,
and I'm the President and CEO
of We the People of Detroit.
We're committed to the
human right to water.
Low income people in Detroit
are having a hard time paying
their water bill.
And they're getting their water shut off.
When the water department comes out
to shut off the water,
they mark it with a blue line
and for many of the residents
it's known as the blue line of shame.
Some people's water is only off
for a matter of days,
others' water has been off
as long as two to three years.
The issue of not having access
to water is a really big deal.
You can lose custody of your children,
you can lose your property,
you can also lose your quality of health.
It just doesn't sit well with me.
Our job is really to meet that human need.
Our services are for those families
that can't afford to get their water
turned back on.
Our water primarily is donated
and then we store it in
one of our water stations
and then it is distributed
out to the community based on need.
The deliveries that we do every week
makes sure that the client has enough
water on an emergency basis
to do some basic things,
flush the toilet, take care
of their basic hygiene,
prepare their food.
Over the last year,
we've served over a thousand families.
Water can unite us.
And so it's out of belovedness
that we approach our water work.
I always like to say
I didn't choose water,
water chose me.